sans inauguration officielle et sans
cérémonial le salon de l'auto la plus
importante de toutes les manifestations
industriel et commercial de l'année
s'est ouvert sur une participation
éclatante où les plus grandes marques
étrangères côtoyer les modèles français
la jaguar anglaise la voiture la plus
rapide du monde avec son volant réglable
a suscité nombre de curiosités
la présence de la mercedes claironnait
la rentrée de l'industrie allemande dans
le circuit mondial
ça nous sommes dans la bataille
pacifique de la ligne automobile
affirmait la ligne française
de son côté la participation italienne
se signalait par une nouvelle création
la voiture tout-terrain campagnola
et les visiteurs qui devaient dès le
jour de l'ouverture se presser autour
des 4000 stands et battre tous les
records d'entrées pouvait s'assurer à
force de km en circuit fermé
une érudition frappé au nom de
l'armorial automobile
point de surprise cependant au salon de
l'auto la voiture mystère dont on parle
et en est resté dans l'ombre mais pour
le visiteur consciencieux la bonne
fatigue d'une gymnastique pratique et la
récompense pour classer ses études et
ses émotions d'une honnête pages
illustrées du salon de l'auto
alors monsieur pierre avis avait
inauguré le salon de l'auto
oui parlons-en du salon de l'auto à te
voilà toi tu m'as bien laissé tomber
quand j'ai vu qu'il était 3h15 j'ai
pensé que tu ne viendrais pas venu
d'ailleurs avec toi mon cher
jean-françois c'est toujours la même
chose tu n'es jamais fichu d'être exaucé
le tube non non je t'assure est là
pourtant ça valait la peine enfin voyons
le salon de l'auto ça n'arrive qu'une
fois par an en toi mais tu savais bien
que ça me faisait plaisir d'y aller avec
toi maintenant maintenant je te dis
c'est toujours la même chose tu promets
rottu promet béthune vient prestation 18
jeunes n'en raconte pas de lit si tu
n'es pas venu et tu n'as rien vu car la
nouvelle par à elle n'a pas vu la
nouvelle tant le sujet rien que pour la
part ça valait quand même la tête
lorsqu'une voiture un châssis impeccable
une carrosserie de luxe un confort
exceptionnel une sécurité absolue une
robustesse à toute épreuve de la
puissance et de la souplesse
elle peut tourner dans un cercle de 9
mètres cinquante de diamètre elle a un
réservoir d'essence de 40 titres une
vitre arrière complètement galbées des
pare chocs d'un profil enveloppe ans qui
avec sa en pas gourmande c'est hydro
sans faille au monde et le moteur ça
développe 42 chevaux qu'elle démarrage
13 secondes pour atteindre 81 eur et sa
table 130
tiens tu n'as pas vu la nouvelle catch
me suces quand tu n'as pas vu les
améliorations le thermomètre sur le
tableau de bord et puis plus de confort
plus de place à l'arrière d'une place
dans le coffre à bagages et ils ont mis
une petite tirette qui commande le
rideau du radiateur croit-il quant à la
think et bien que ces barres est la
nouvelle direction qui travaillent sur
hulu rouge la remplace l'ancienne qui
travaillaient parmi ces secteurs des
pare chocs ont été abaissés poirier
renforcer les clignotants de direction
déplacer à et surtout le coffre
maintenant beaucoup plus spacieux bouby
233 des six mètres cubes au lieu de 198
200 entendu parfaitement parfaitement
pas la 203e la cylindrée du moteur a été
augmentée faut le vermont ils ont changé
le bouchon du réservoir d'essence
oui maintenant il est enfermé dans un
logement spécifier les bougies elle dit
sont toujours aussi dans leur logement
spéciale du dandy drôle à tort de ne pas
porter plus d'intérêt aux bougies 1
ainsi la bougie encore un don quand on
en rit encore un dont mon petit jean
françois mais la bougie c'est
l'étincelle c'est l'esprit c'est l'âme
de la boîte du les échos net et de
bougies et déployé porte était couche en
nylon et et et techno and on ne
plaisante pas avec les pneus c'est
essentiel et les pneus sur une voiture
enfin voyons c'est capital tu dois
comprendre que tout roule sur le pneu
six voix j'ai vu des plus en textile à
haute ténacité et ben un bon pneu c'est
la vie et celle des autres
souviens toi du proverbe ne roulait pas
sur des +3 plus est les derniers
kilomètres peut vous coûter très cher en
tout cas la citroën est toujours en
bonne place elle maintient ses modèles
classiques il en déplacement dernier jeu
l'an dernier était d'ailleurs identique
à celui des précédentes et se déshabille
oui ma femme toujours solidité tenue de
route et un coffre améliorer l améliorer
enfin il somme toute un joli salon wii
un joli 5 mois
fidèle au rendez vous d'octobre le salon
de l'auto a ouvert ses portes
renouant une tradition le président de
gaulle a inauguré en compagnie de
monsieur jamais ministre de l'industrie
et du commerce chez renault exportateurs
dans 98 pays
la floride que présente cette hôtesse de
nationalité du terrain la dauphine a
acquis cette année une nouvelle
suspension baptisé aéro stable qui donne
à en juger d'excellents résultats
chez peugeot le moteur à huile lourde
s'applique à toute la gamme des 403 il
doit permettre une économie de 50 % en
valeurs monétaires par rapport au moteur
à essence
autre innovation 403 et 203 sont dotés
du ventilateur débrayable automatique
amélioration très appréciable en
économie et en gagne puissant
parmi les 400 modèles exposés une
nouveauté française la face il ya dont
le constructeur aspirent au titre de
christian dior de la voiture
e
lang liens forts de britanniques acquis
l'étrange des coupures de l'ariège
confère un profil pour le moins
inhabituel
la cadillac dessiné par remo le vix qui
écrivit là les verts se vend mal
la falcon 14e chevaux que l'amérique
donne comme voitures européennes
économique
enfin la ds19 a fait un grand pas en
avant
la montre du tableau de bord est
maintenant électrique
dans ce cas je commencerai par est-ce
que la monde
un siècle a passé depuis qu'un belge de
paris etienne le noir créa la première
voiture dont le moteur du mans breveté
utiliser un mélange détonnant à base de
vapeur de pétrole l'allumage été
provoquée par une étincelle électrique
éclatant entre deux files de platine et
ça marchait
alphonse beau de rochas perfectionna
l'invention
il eut l'idée de comprimer le mélange
détonnant avant de l'enflammer
édifiant ainsi la théorie du moteur à
quatre temps mais il fallut attendre 26
ans pour que les allemands daimler est
née bac utilisent ces théories pour
créer le moteur à quatre temps et ce
furent deux firmes françaises qui
achetèrent à daimler le brevet de son
moteur et c'est ainsi que d'une part
messieurs panhard et levassor mis au
point dans leur usine d'ivry à paris la
première automobile à moteur à quatre
temps tandis que d'autre part on en
faisait autant chez peugeot c'était en
les voitures électriques ou les voitures
à vapeur représentée par les deux dion
bouton et les serpolet été condamné on
le vit bien lors des grandes
compétitions sur route que s'adjugèrent
très vite les voitures à pétrole
en 1900 la france berceau de cette
industrie compte déjà deux 1997
véhicules en circulation
en 1901 5386 en 1913 108000 temps
lointains dont les images nous arrache
un sourire d'attendrissement avec leur
poudre big leur cache poussière et leur
voile est
le premier code de la route il convient
de le signaler n'acquittent en 1899 il
portait la signature du président emile
loubet cette ambiance d'une époque
révolue
le tout paris a pu s'y plonger à
l'occasion du 50ème salon de l'auto car
c'est à la fois aux fans de l'automobile
d'aujourd'hui et d'hier que s'est ouvert
sur les champs-elysées le pub renault
quatre mille personnes y ont fait un
pèlerinage aux temps héroïques en
compagnie de monsieur dreyfus président
directeur général de la régie d'yves
montand de ray sugar robinson et de
maurice chevalier
mais au 50ème salon
cinq ans après l'invention de lenoir ce
ne sont pas les souvenirs du passé qui
est venu chercher la foule innombrable
des conducteurs et candidat conducteur
d'aujourd'hui une vision des voitures de
demain peut-être aux formes vertigineuse
un aperçu sur le nouveau moteur rotatif
version révolutionnaire de notre quatre
temps et prouver
avant tout cette eau voiture de grande
série que la foule a porté son attention
faire chez peugeot par exemple la
connaissance du nouveau vilebrequin à
cinq paliers qui équipe la 404 changer
encore une fois la dernière née des
usines de sochaux et vérifier la plus
grande habitabilité des places arrière
ou encore apprécier le confort de la
berline équipée du nouveau moteur diesel
1948 cm qu on ne négligera pas de jeter
un regard attentif aux pneumatiques
élément important de la sécurité dont
les derniers nés se prévalent de leur
longue durée on appréciera qu'après la
r8 renouer type aujourd'hui la dauphine
de freins à disque et de boîtes
automatiques
on surveillera le détail car on est
devenues difficiles depuis le noir
le mariage six poèmes fiat s'il n'était
pas encore consommé a cependant défrayé
la chronique du 55e salon de
l'automobile de paris
vous semblez marque présenter leurs
modèles à une foule toujours plus
nombreuse de visiteurs
deux nouveautés françaises ont polarisé
la curiosité chez renault la petite
soeur de la r16 la renault 6 chez
peugeot la 504 avec elle la firme de
sochaux élargit sa gamme vers le haut
dans la cylindrée des 1800 centimètres
cubes et se présente ainsi comme un
redoutable concurrent sur le marché
européen parmi tous les modèles éprouvés
404 et 204 bénéficie d'améliorations
notables freins à disque à l'avant sur
la 404 barre anti dévers à l'avant et à
l'arrière sur la 204 cimetière pour sa
part poursuit sur une grande échelle
la diversification dans la
standardisation
la diversification est aussi à l'ordre
du jour dans les pneumatiques domaine où
un effort considérable a été effectué
pour répondre avec sécurité aux vitesses
extraits
face aux voitures françaises la
conférence européenne ne manque
évidemment pas d'atouts elle aligne à ce
55e salon quelques solides coursier de
hautes écoles
et puis voici la part du rêve
l'alfa romeo 33 carabeau de bertone
modeste avec un moteur électrique sur
chaque roue arrière la voiture
électronique des frères jarret c'est
peut-être l'avenir
mais le passé compte aussi des adeptes
et la copie de la bugatti type 35 de
1927 troublera de jeunes regardent avis
elles sont toutes là les marques
disparues tombés au champ d'honneur de
l'industrialisation fidèles autant grand
père était jeune et où les coussins de
cuir été fait chez hermès elles sont les
voisines au salon de rutilants de
nouveautés mais chacune a eu elle aussi
son salon il ya bien longtemps
cent mille deux cent mille trois cent
mille kilomètres mais pour les réunir il
a d'abord fallu les arracher à leurs
propriétaires les collectionneurs
justement ont confié les walker un la
condition que les voitures soient dans
un état le cycle ou été total et c'est
ce qui explique justement la présence de
ces barrières que personnellement en
tant que styliste esthéticiens stlg taux
très laide lorsqu'il faut pas oublier
une chose que ces watts journal
représente un nom fantastique de deux
heures de travail de remise en état et
c'est ce qu'ils ont et l'emballer j'ai
réussi à les persuader en leur disant je
suis moi même mon coach ne suis je pas
que moi-même mes voitures mais je me
suis ratant sion certaines de ces
voitures ont demandé près de trois ans
de restauration
trois ans de recherche de pièces
manquantes dans le monde entier
trois ans pour passer de l'état d'épave
à celui de pièces de collection
elles sont estimées plus cher que toutes
les ferrari rolls et maserati 9 des
stands voisins
parmi ces anciens on peut découvrir des
vedettes l'amilcar et la balle aux de
borsalino la de dion bouton du film la
bande à bonnot il ne manque que la panne
art et levassor qui fut longtemps
attendus à la porte du garage on
l'attend toujours
ou c'est en cuir tableau de bord de bois
précieux lanternes en cuivre elles sont
les représentantes de l'époque où les
voitures se faisait sur mesure un
carrossier dessiner une carrosserie à la
convenance du propriétaire
ces voitures étaient des pièces uniques
maintenant chacun se glisse dans son pub
à se déplacer qui porte le même nom de
voiture mais si nos voitures sont mornes
elles ont aussi baissé de prix car il ne
faut pas oublier que déjà à l'époque ces
automobiles étaient d'exception et que
seuls quelques privilégiés pouvait se
les offrir
mais cela ne nous empêchera pas d'aller
les admire au salon et peut-être
aura-t-on la chance d'apercevoir l'ombre
de l'homme à l'hispano dévalant les
routes françaises au volant de sa
torpeur dos à plus de 80 kilomètres
heure
vous avez un stand à garder faire très
attention aux risques de vol on risque
la 110e beaucoup de choses
vous vous retournez sur le stand retours
neigeux toute la nuit
je tenais nous embourber 3 c'est très
dangereux
et alors faites très attention et s'il a
quelque chose vous prévenez
immédiatement
alors maintenant venait
encore
si la gs plus d'un million une amie on
souhaite une suspension mais
consommation on ne veux pas causer
coloris pas mal bon bras ouverts oui
très bonne conscience
paris café
5 à 9 8 6 chevaux c'est la même celle là
c'est pas la même c'est l'asse 2220 cell
jeu 1220 parce que là c'est là c'est la
gs courant
il y en a il ya là comme un chien
maintenant elle met pas de l'argent avec
une course comme ça je suis sur cette
belle mère dans les trois peut-être 3,4
me font la manche
elle vous prie de la gauche n'a aucun
rapport qu'est-ce qui a soufflé une
voiture probablement ses rôles au sein
d' ici greno probablement le vrai que
j'ai moi même temps par sa vitesse
remarquez bien et surtout pas la
suspension qui je crois se rapproche le
plus la ds ce jour
j'ai juste une 403 j'ai trouvé très
bonne voiture excellente voiture sans
histoire jamais de problème très bonne
voiture d'essai encore longtemps
une chose qui vous surprendre c'est la
petitesse des moteurs américains pour
une oeuvre est assez forte
c'est là à 780 ces rutilants pour moi
c'est du juge et aux yeux oui ça tient
bien la route tue pas le problème
mercedes à bruxelles en voiture le cher
très cher
porsche excellente voiture excellent
très robuste aussi moteur à l'arrière
aussi ce n'est pas tout le monde d'avoir
piraté voiture anglaise vous savez le
marché français or la rolls je vous
dirais gym yoox hershey's
il ya une très bonne voiture le
tchécoslovaque la cena comme ont déjà
fait plus de la marque qu'un des points
en terre le 1er mai veille le moteur
fait n'est pas 100 chevaux en tout cas
la loi la voiture se porte bien on peut
le dire dans le monde actuel oui oui oui
madame monsieur bonsoir le président
laïb
monsieur pompidou a inauguré le salon de
l'auto 73 il a voulu donner à sa
présence porte de versailles et à son
geste
une signification encore plus nette que
les années précédentes en raison du
développement social de loto des
problèmes qu'il pose pour la sécurité
l'urbanisme et la pollution
c'est en présence du public que monsieur
georges pompidou a visité ce 60e salon
arrêt prolongé au stand peugeot le coupé
104 a retenu l'attention du président
puis citroën avec le nouveau moteur bi
rotor équipant un modèle vs quand vous
inauguré le salon de 1977 vous en verrez
beaucoup at on dit au président réponse
je le souhaite car cela m'intéresse
nouveaux arrêts au stand chrysler france
et renault avant les grandes marques
étrangères fiat volkswagen mercedes
general motors et que c'était monsieur
pompidou a également manifesté beaucoup
d'intérêt pour la dernière née déjà
vedette la minima très remarqué enfin
l'appart est que le président de la
république a eu avec monsieur marcellin
à l'issue de la visite
alors quand on viole les règlements il
faut se faire arrêter
et si l'envié est là mais moi je vole
pas les règlements mais je constate que
dans les règles et que les agents
regarda hier pour resserrer un peu les
vices par ici on va le lui en veux que
les taxis et les autobus puissent
circuler sur tout le monde puisse
circuler que les piétons ne soit pas
comme des faisans à la chasse locale et
ben il faut que vous serrez directement
voilà presque bournac d'assister
les américains commencent en avoir assez
des grosses américaines à l'occasion du
salon la general motors frappe un grand
coup
elle présente la ce caillou c'est une
sous compacte entendez par là une
voiture de dimensions inférieures à la
normale américaine mais encore
respectable à l'échelle européenne
quatre mètres 55 c'est un coupé
théoriquement de quatre places mais en
fait une fois les sièges avant reculer
c'est une de plus de l'équipement
intérieur est très complet appuie-tête
ceinture enrouleur à rappelle sonore et
boîtes de vitesses à trois rapports
automatiques
le moteur bien américain est un 6
cylindres de 22 chevaux vitesse de
pointe 180 km/heure consommation
raisonnable de 12 à 14 8 sièges arrière
rabattables et route secours goff la dda
skyhawk et donc la réponse de l'amérique
à l'europe
visible pour la première fois au salon
de paris elle sera commercialisée au
début de l'année prochaine au prix de 40
mille francs
chez simca ce n'est pas la révolution
pas de nouveauté des améliorations par
ci par là de nouveaux tableaux de bord
beaucoup plus lisible et nous on sent
qu'il peut rouler à l'essence ordinaire
en revanche matra simca s'est adjoint
les services d'un couturier qui a revu
et corrigé le cheval de bataille de
matra simca la bagheera et chez simca
n'envisage maintenant sérieusement une
collaboration étroite avec courrèges qui
habille les sept voitures vendues 33
mille francs regardez bien cette voiture
vous allez être les premiers au monde
râle à découvrir ce n'est ni la golf de
volkswagen ni la fiat 127 c'est l'audi
50 ce sera la rivale directe de la
renault 5 puisqu'elle fait exactement la
même longueur 3 mètres 50
après un bref essai effectué moitié sur
route moitié en milieu urbain l'audi 50
nous a laissé une très bonne impression
la tenue de route est étonnante
le silence à l'intérieur de l'habitacle
surprenant pour une petite cylindrée
en effet l'audi 50 reçoit un moteur
entièrement nouveau onze centimètres
cubes six chevaux fiscaux 140 ou 150
kilomètres/heure selon les versions
monté transversalement ce moteur est
d'une grande souplesse même à bas régime
les reprises ne pose aucun problème
l'intérieur sauve comme c'est de coutume
chez audi est complet l'accès aux places
arrière est facile et le hayon arrière
découvre un coffre relativement
important
toutefois l'absence d'un servofrein
proposé en option se fait cruellement
sentir lors des freinages le
compte-tours lui aussi proposé en option
brille également par son absence est à
notre avis le volant d'un diamètre trop
importants complique les manoeuvres
notamment en ville
l'audi 50 sera commercialisé en france
début 1975
quant à son prix il devrait se situer
aux alentours de 16 mille francs 1975 à
peugeot porter son effort sur le coupé
le cabriolet 504 qui reçoivent ce moteur
fruit de l'association avec renault et
volvo
c'est un 6 cylindres en aluminium de 2
litres 6
avec ce moteur peugeot a plus visés
l'agrément le confort de conduite et la
sécurité que les performances puisque la
vitesse de point de ses 500 4 n'est que
286 km heure
renault n'a quant à lui pas attendu le
salon pour sortir la r5 et laisse en
effet depuis le mois de mai la ls roule
sur toutes les routes françaises
il est vrai qu'elle avait été pensé et
conçu bien avant la crise perd 5 et
laisse son empreinte le moteur de la r12
ce qui lui procure plus de souplesse et
de puissance le salon de paris ne vois
donc fleurir dans la gamme renault que
des nouvelle calandre et de nouveaux
garnissages de sièges
en revanche la présentation de l'engin
de sécurité renault le prv est très
attendue pour la première fois vous
voyez actuellement ce que sera peut être
votre voiture dans quelques années le
bervet est une voiture laboratoire qui
concilie l'agrément des automobiles
d'aujourd'hui avec la sécurité des
voitures de demain
car renault a repris le maximum
d'éléments existants actuellement sur
ces modèles respectant par là même la
notion de sécurité active bien entendu à
l'intérieur de l'habitacle on a
particulièrement soigné le rembourrage
et la résistance les appuie têtes sont
fixes sur les cje avant et éclipse sable
sur les sièges arrière le tableau de
bord est volontairement privé de gadgets
et d'accessoires superflus
une dernière précision le bervet ne sera
jamais commercialisé
car il est impossible de fixer son prix
et le japon et bien la production
japonaise n'est pas absente du salon de
paris
la toyota corona 1800 mark 1 arrive en
france
c'est une berline quatre portes dont le
principal attrait et son prix 22 mille
francs la finition est particulièrement
soigné la boîte de vitesses et soit 5
rapports soient automatiques
le moteur d'une cylindrée de 1800
centimètres cubes autorise une vitesse
de pointe de 170 km up
tout comme renault citroën lui aussi n'a
pas attendu le 3 octobre pour présenter
la vraie vedette du salon la cx en
laponie il ya quelques semaines la cx
roule maintenant sur la plupart des
routes françaises
l'asx est une voiture synthèse qui
reprend tout ce qui a fait le succès de
citroën depuis la traction avant c'est
une voiture sage qui en dépit de ses
onze chevaux reçoit un très bon accueil
auprès du public
la gamme citroën 1975 se distingue par
des modifications touchant
principalement la présentation et
l'équipement des phares rectangulaires
pour les deux shows 4 et 6 une extension
de la gamme gs puisque trois nouveaux
modèles apparaissent notamment la gsx de
et la gs palace
le salon de l'automobile qui se tient
tous les deux ans à paris est un moment
important pour tous les constructeurs
comme pour les usagers d'ailleurs en
effet cette manifestation vous le savez
fait office de test sur la santé du
marché automobile français et
international
ce matin la régie renault doit souffler
si j'ose dire puisque le plan proposé
par monsieur bernard arnault le pdg de
la régie a été acceptée par les
syndicats qui au passage ont obtenu gain
de cause sur leurs revendications
immédiates concernant les congés mobiles
le pouvoir d'achat renault qui profitent
de ce salon pour présenter la supercinq
ce ne sera pas la seule nouveauté de ce
grand rassemblement automobile jean
claude renaud la super 5 est le seul
vrai nouveau modèle français du salon et
renault la mise en bonne place en fait
les nouveautés sont plus dans des
versions différentes de modèles
existants que dans des modèles nouveau
mais bernard anne ont expliqué aux
journalistes étrangers quand 86 toute la
gamme renault serait renouvelée avec
prometic un retour du groupe à l'
équilibre financier
le pdg de la régie expliqué aussi qu'il
compte vendre en 87 600 mille voitures
aux américains dont cette alliance
décapotable réservé aux états unis
c'est dommage
autre fierté de renault la r25 v6 turbo
la reine qui s'attaque aux belles
allemandes 225 km heure système
antiblocage de roues en série n'est plus
de 180 mille francs dans sa version
limousine plus luxueuse elle atteint 215
milles francs à noter encore la régie
l'espace el hadid txeroki nouvelle venue
sur le marché français du côté de psa
c'est citroën qui affiche le plus de
nouvelles versions avec une surprise
pour les artisans deux utilitaires sur
la base de la vise à laisser 15e et d
epuis la bx 19 j'étais là visages
étaient cousines de la 205 gti de
peugeot et enfin le fleuron la cx 25 gti
turbo 220 km heure près de 180 mille ans
chez peugeot outre une 305 gtx la 205
s'apprête à avaler de nouvelles parts du
marché
averses avec ses versions x en 3 portes
à noter qu'un constructeur français se
décide enfin équilibre à équiper ses
voitures d'un toit ouvrant
transparent et pour terminer voici
l'écho 2002 citroën un prototype
expérimental
celui là ne roulent pas mais la future
de chevaux qui sera peut être au
prochain salon en 86 pourrait bien lui
ressemble une dernière visite au salon
de l'auto qui fermera ses portes demain
- visiteurs qu'il y a deux ans la
fréquentation a baissé semble-t-il
d'environ 20%
cela dit dans ce salon perdu parmi les
stands rutilants des grands
constructeurs
daniel lauclair a repéré un petit
français qui ne manque pas de courage
avec une équipe quasiment artisanale
dans son atelier de cholet il a conçu et
fabrique une voiture de sport de très
bon niveau et dont il espère vendre 200
exemplaires par an ce constructeur
marginal s'appelait le cloud poireaux et
sa voiture l'aventurisme
des allures italienne un intérieur très
british
la puissance allemande
et pourtant la venturi d'une voiture
100% française elle est la création d'un
vendéen de 40 ans l'hôte poireau qui a
passé près de vingt ans de sa vie dans
les ateliers de mécanique pour enfin
réaliser son rêve construire sa propre
voiture
en tout cas l'aboutissement d'un rêve de
jeunesse
et
cinq années passées chez alpine plus
d'une douzaine d'années passées chez
heuliez ont permis d'assimiler à la fois
les techniques de la mécanique et la
technique de la carrosserie et cela me
permet de réaliser ce projet venturi qui
représente je crois un fleuron
d'automobiles françaises en tout cas
dans dé bonnes réalisations classique et
j'espère que cette voiture aura toutes
les qualités nécessaires
grand succès la venturi a effectué ses
premiers tours de roue sur le circuit
bugatti au mans
ses qualités routières sont indéniables
et équipé d'un moteur v6 turgot prv
peugeot renault volvo
d'une cylindrée de 2000 450 centimètres
cube pour une puissance de 200 ch pour
bref un petit bolide 260 km/heure pied
au plancher le km en moins de 27
secondes
elle est dans la lignée des alpine
porsche et autres ferrari
d'ailleurs pour développer son image de
marque
l'aventuré a choisi la fif l'an prochain
elle disputera le championnat de france
de production elle a déjà des
inconditionnels 25 commandes au salon
c'est pas mal car cette petite merveille
artisanale n'est pas à la portée de
toutes les bourses
près de 300 mille francs ça aussi c'est
l'aventuré le mondial de l'automobile
porte de versailles à paris il a été
inauguré aujourd'hui par jacques chirac
dès demain le grand public pourra les
découvrir les nouveautés et ce jusqu'au
15 octobre
des visiteurs qui pourrait être un peu
perdu depuis deux ans les fusions et
différents mariages ont conduit les
groupes a rassemblé leurs marques sur
les mêmes stands claude guaino et jean
michel millet au dernier mondial de
paris il ya deux ans il était encore le
numéro deux de renault
aujourd'hui carlos ghosn est à la tête
de nissan envoyé à tokyo pour remettre
le deuxième constructeur japonais en
état de marche
il est aussi comptable des 35 milliards
que renault qui a investi je suis
aujourd'hui officiellement le patron de
nissan
je suis responsable de lisa en même
temps si je suis le président de nissan
c'est quelque part parce que il ya eu
une alliance signée entre renault et
nissan et au mondial cela se voit les
deux marques partagent le même périmètre
en attendant de partager bientôt
certains modèles la dimension mondiale
apporte à renault façonnement plus de
taille c'est à dire puisque capacités
technologiques qu'il n'en avait plus de
débouchés pour ses voitures
je pense que ça apporte un changement
d'esprit à l'entreprise une entreprise
mondiale niveau d'enthousiasmé un niveau
de légitimité et la concurrence
manifeste la même fierté
ford a rassemblé sa famille de marques
autour de son stand avec jaguar mazda et
volvo fiat n'a pas encore rejoint gm
opel le mariage est trop récent
l'exception c'est bmw qui se retrouve
seul après l'échec de sa fusion avec
rover le sommet est atteint par fox
hagen qui a rassemblé sa famille
nombreuse dans le hall 3 8 marques
différentes seat et skoda côtoyant la
prestigieuse rolls royce le mondial
cette année est le reflet de deux années
de concentration je crois qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez d'une part des constructeurs
qui avaient envie de fusionner et qu'ils
ont fait puisqu'il n'y a plus de torts
d'idées à la fusion disponibles et
d'autres comme toyota comme face à genk
bmw que monde a comme psa peugeot
citroën qui pensent que c'est pas une
bonne idée de faire des fusions et yeux
ne feront pas non plus donc je crois que
la période de fusion elle est maintenant
derrière nous il resterait bien le
coréen daewoo en faillite mais dont
personne ne veut ceci nous amène au
mondial de l'automobile qui a ouvert ses
portes ce matin au public un événement
populaire pour la seule journée
d'aujourd'hui cent mille visiteurs et
les files d'attentes s'allongent et bien
avant l'ouverture des portes vincent
fourcadier breeam bre
à peine deux jours de formation et déjà
les ans d'une vendeuse professionnels de
venir pédaler fort l'a tellement qu'ils
sont techniques et à mesure au départ de
tout connaître de la matière et pendant
deux semaines les questions ne vont pas
manquer le mondial de l'automobile ouvre
ses portes
si les concepts car comme cette peugeot
907 attire toujours les regards les
vedettes de cette édition ce sont les
mini monospace format réduit et gros
succès pour la 1007 avec portes
coulissantes
même enthousiasme pour sa concurrente la
modus de renault l'espace d'une journée
les toutes petites sont devenues de
vraies grandes
déjà quand vous la regardez les très
belles courses d'avant garde une petite
bazire
elle manque de coffre j'ai flashé sur
les phares au derrière surtout ils tous
les petits gadgets 480 exposants venus
de 26 pays
soixante modèles dévoilés en exclusivité
un million et demi de visiteurs attendus
le mondial de l'automobile devenu au fil
des éditions le salon de tous les
records et d un plus grand salon ce sont
maintenant dans le monde reconnu par
tous les visiteurs et les professionnels
séparés qui a pas compris la tête
maintenant devant francfort tokyo
détroit et genève le salon parisien
choisi par ferrari pour dévoiler sa
toute nouvelle f430 l'une des rares
voitures que tout le monde peut
photographier mais dans laquelle
personne ou presque n'a le droit de
monter